A cult classic beloved by its legions of devoted
fans, Veronica Mars put a fresh spin on the
TV mystery genre.
Former young adult novel author Rob Thomas
created the show, a modern-day combination
of noir and Nancy Drew, and it ran for three
seasons on UPN and the CW.
Years later, the show would be resurrected
as a successfully crowdfunded movie.
Let's explore the real reasons why Veronica
Mars was canceled.
Low ratings
Television networks are businesses, and low-rated
shows tend to be poor investments.
“This serves as a preemptive apology for
the conversation that’s about to take place.”
In its first season back in the Fall of 2004,
Veronica Mars ranked a dismal #148 out of
156 total shows.
It ticked up a bit to #145 in its second season,
and #138 in its third and final year.
All the while, total viewership held steady
at about 2.5 million viewers.
“Tada”
Said CW entertainment president Dawn Ostroff
at a TV industry event shortly after the cancellation:
"We really tried every single year to bring
in more viewers and we just weren't able to
crack it."
Maybe that's true, but the network didn't
do Veronica Mars any favors by scheduling
it against Fox's American Idol at the peak
of its popularity.
“That is slightly disturbing.”
Tough fit with the CW
In 2006, the two struggling networks, the
WB and UPN, merged into a new network called
the CW, which became Veronica Mars' new home.
“This face, right here.
My over the moon face.”
Sadly, despite surviving the merger, it wasn't
an easy fit.
Even though CW corporate sibling Warner Bros.
Studios produced Veronica Mars, it was canceled
because it couldn't draw in new viewers.
“So are you gonna tell me why I am here,
or should I just sit back and enjoy your impression
of a mildly constipated David Caruso.”
That's because the CW was going after a couple
of very specific audience niches, and Veronica
Mars—a difficult-to-categorize show that
was a little funny and a little dramatic—didn't
fit in with the vampires and superheroes.
Ahead of its time
Veronica Mars ran on broadcast TV just before
the so-called "Second Golden Age of Television,"
and before streaming services opened up new
opportunities for quirkier shows like the
kind Rob Thomas creates.
Before shows like Breaking Bad and Game of
Thrones found accolades for their intricate
plotting that required viewers to pay close
attention and watch every episode, TV shows
that dared to be innovative, cinematic, and
complicated were often critically acclaimed
but commercially ignored.
Veronica Mars aired around the same time as
Arrested Development, another show that pulled
in a small but devoted audience of fans who
appreciated precision.
“Coo Coo cacha.
Coo Coo cacha.”
“What are you doing?”
“Michael and women, a-coodle-doodle-do.
“That is what I was just telling him.”
“ a-coodle-doodle-do.”
“Cha”
No reboot
While Veronica Mars was still on the air,
some CW executives asked Thomas to write a
show about rookie cops.
He countered with the idea of making the fourth
season of Veronica Mars jump forward in time
to show Veronica in her first year as an FBI
agent, and they produced a pilot presentation:
a mini-episode about 12 minutes long.
While well-received by CW brass, the reboot
wasn't meant to be—Thomas explained in an
interview that he thinks CBS president Les
Moonves, killed it:
“We went from dead to back on the air to
dead again very quickly.
Our Hail Mary pass came very close to working
but didn’t quite get past all the filters
it needed to.”
Moving on
Probably seeing the writing on the wall, Thomas
had already secured his next gig by the time
the series was wrapping up its third season.
“Those days are over and it is time to move
on.”
He was hired on as a writer and producer for
ABC's Miss Guided, a sitcom starring Judy
Greer as a high school guidance counselor.
Thomas was quickly promoted to showrunner
and executive producer, but left the series
after only a few weeks due to creative differences.
Miss Guided was ultimately a midseason replacement
that aired only seven episodes in the spring
of 2008, freeing up Greer to move on to better
things.
Resurrection
Veronica Mars's hardcore fans couldn't let
go, and neither could the show's talent . For
years after the cancellation, Rob Thomas and
star Kristen Bell mentioned the possibility
of a movie in interviews.
It seemed like a longshot for a studio to
finance a big-screen version of a show very
few people watched.
“When are we going to do this whole Veronica
Mars movie, huh.”
“I don’t know, you got a couple million
dollars lying around?”
But then along came Kickstarter.
In March 2013, Thomas launched a campaign
to finance the movie directly from fans.
Within 30 days, the project had collected
an astonishing $5.7 million.
“Wait for it… ohhhhh.”
“Yeah”
“I love all 91 thousand of you.”
“From the whole cast, thank you so very
much.”
Thomas took a screenplay and his Kickstarter
money to Warner Bros., and the studio kicked
in a few more million to get the movie made.
It was released to theaters and to video-on-demand
platforms in March 2014.
Thanks for watching!
Subscribe to our YouTube channel to watch
more videos like the one you just saw.
And leave us a comment to let us know what
you loved most about Veronica Mars.